Si os digo la palabra JAPÓN, estoy seguro
de que todos pensaréis en el manga, los videojuegos
o las empresas tecnológicas.
Sin ir más lejos, TOKIO, parece salida de
una película de ciencia ficción.
Es la metrópoli más grande del planeta con
más de 30 millones de habitantes y tiene
los trenes más rápidos, las televisiones
más modernas y hasta robots que parecen humanos.
En otras palabras, que a simple vista, nadie
diría que Japón está al borde del colapso
económico ¿Verdad?
Sin embargo, este país lleva dos décadas
completamente estancado… ¡Y eso no es lo
peor!
Japón es el país más endeudado del mundo
entero.
Deben más de dos veces su producto interior
bruto.
Y su población está decreciendo a pasos
agigantados.
Casi no hay dinero para pagar las pensiones
y los japoneses hacen jornadas laborales interminables
y apenas tienen vacaciones.
Os lo hemos dicho muchas veces aquí, en VisualPolitik,
esos grandes gigantes nipones como Hitachi
o Panasonic están perdiendo la carrera frente
a empresas mucho más innovadoras en China
o Estados Unidos.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
pueden cambiar!
Sí, me estoy refiriendo a los JUEGOS OLÍMPICOS
de TOKIO 2020.
Una oportunidad única para que el país entero
se vista de gala y se convierta en el centro
de atención de todo el planeta.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde que Japón
ganó la candidatura, en el año 2013, el
turismo se ha disparado de la noche a la mañana.
Y lo mismo ha ocurrido con la inversión privada.
Para el 2020, Tokio tendrá nada menos que
45 nuevos rascacielos.
Y, por ejemplo, Panasonic va a colocar paneles
solares de última generación por toda la
ciudad para que los asistentes a los juegos
puedan cargar sus coches eléctricos.
Y SONY va a estrenar sus televisiones en formato
8K para retransmitir el evento.
Sí, habéis oído bien.
Si todavía no nos hemos acostumbrado al 4K,
dentro de poco vamos a tener el 8K, que permitirá
que veamos hasta las costuras de las camisetas
de los atletas.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no todo es
tan bonito!
Veréis, cuando Tokio ganó la candidatura
olímpica, tenía presupuestado gastarse unos
6500 millones de dólares.
Por dar un poco de contexto, ese dinero es
más de lo que costó la T4 de Madrid, que
es uno de los aeropuertos más grandes de
Europa.
Pero, una vez han empezado con las obras,
ya llevan gastado más del doble ¡Y todavía
no han terminado!
No está nada mal si tenemos en cuenta que
el país del Sol Naciente ya lleva una deuda
acumulada de más del 230% de su PIB.
Así que ¿Hasta qué punto estos juegos olímpicos
van a ser una oportunidad o un desastre para
Japón?
¿De verdad los Juegos Olímpicos son algo
bueno para los anfitriones?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia…
¿UNA FALACIA OLÍMPICA?
Hay pocas cosas que levanten el orgullo nacional
que unos juegos olímpicos.
Por supuesto que a todos nos gusta presumir
de las medallas de oro que tiene nuestro país.
Pero lo que realmente sube el ego patriótico
es ser el anfitrión de unos juegos.
Es tal el fervor que genera un evento como
este que, prácticamente, parece que todo
el mundo, independientemente de su ideología,
está de acuerdo en que organizar unos juegos
olímpicos es bueno para un país.
Sin embargo, dentro del mundo de los economistas,
las cosas no están tan claras.
Es más, seamos honestos, los argumentos a
favor de ser el anfitrión de unas olimpiadas
son ¿Cómo decirlo?
Tan incongruentes que parecen un guión de
PERDIDOS.
Fijaos, según un informe del BANCO DE JAPÓN,
los efectos de los Juegos Olímpicos de Tokio
se están notando incluso antes de que se
hayan celebrado.
Concretamente, el año en el que el Comité
Olímpico Internacional nombró a la capital
japonesa como ciudad anfitriona, se dio el
pistoletazo de salida para que todo el mundo
reconozca al país entero como un destino
fantástico para las inversiones.
Uno de sus principales argumentos es que si
tu ciudad gana la nominación olímpica te
permite entrar por la puerta grande en todas
esas grandes organizaciones internacionales
en las que todo país querría ser miembro
¿Queréis ejemplos?
¡Aquí los tenéis!
Barcelona empezó a organizar sus juegos en
el año 1986.
Y justo ese mismo año, España entró en
la Unión Europea.
Beijing fue nombrada anfitriona olímpica
en 2001 ¡El mismo año en el que entró a
formar parte de la Organización Mundial del
Comercio!
Vamos, que parecen argumentos irrefutables
¿Verdad?
Pues… esperad un momento porque esto es
un ejemplo de libro de falacia de correlación.
En otras palabras el hecho de que España
entrara en la Unión Europea en el mismo año
que Barcelona fuera elegida como anfitriona
olímpica no significa que lo uno fuera causa
de lo otro.
De hecho, tanto Grecia como Portugal se convirtieron
en miembros del mismo club sin tener que organizar
ningún evento deportivo.
¡Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
¿Qué hay de la exposición internacional?
Durante los 15 días que duran los juegos,
todo el mundo está pendiente de lo que ocurre
en tu país.
Hablamos del mayor acontecimiento deportivo
del mundo… ¿O tal vez no?
Veréis, las Olimpiadas de Londres de 2012,
consiguieron una audiencia media de 31 millones
de espectadores en un país como Estados Unidos.
Para que lo comparemos, eso es algo así como
dos veces lo que consigue un episodio de Juego
de Tronos.
Es cierto, no está nada mal ¿Pero qué ha
ocurrido con el resto de Juegos Olímpicos?
Pues, por ejemplo, los juegos de Invierno
de Sochi, 2014, ni siquiera llegaron a los
22 millones de espectadores y los de Río
2016 se quedaron en los 26 millones.
Pueden parecer cifras muy altas pero se quedan
en nada si las comparamos con las de otros
eventos mucho más baratos como la SUPERBOWL,
que, sin ir más lejos, en 2016, superó los
110 millones de espectadores.
En otras palabras, que aunque las olimpiadas
se ven en todo el mundo, cuando miramos las
cifras de audiencia país por país, los números
no son tan impresionantes.
Y esto se traduce en que la percepción que
los ciudadanos tienen de un país tampoco
cambia demasiado… al menos, no cambia para
bien.
En un studio sobre el impacto de las Olimpiadas
de Sidney del año 2000, los investigadores
entrevistaron a gente de distintos países
un año antes y un año después de los juegos.
Encontraron muy pocos cambios en las percepciones
con una excepción sorprendente.
Los sudafricanos estaban descontentos con
Australia por el modo en el que se habían
resaltado los problemas con los aborígenes
en los medios sudafricanos”.
Sin embargo, hay algo que parece indiscutible:
los Juegos Olímpicos mejoran el turismo de
un país.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde que Tokio
fue elegida como anfitriona, el turismo en
Japón se ha multiplicado.
Han pasado de apenas recibir visitantes del
extranjero a tener más de 24 millones de
personas el año pasado.
En un país donde apenas había trabajo para
los hoteles, ahora ha nacido un nuevo sector
económico.
Un sector que atrae ingentes cantidades de
dinero del extranjero ¿A quién no le puede
gustar algo así?
Pues… esperad un momento porque incluso
estas cifras son bastante discutibles.
Por supuesto, el turismo en Japón he crecido
una auténtica barbaridad.
Pero ¿Sabéis que otro país ha crecido a
un ritmo similar en los últimos años?
Chile y Tailandia.
Y no hace falta que lo busquéis, ya os lo
digo desde aquí… ninguno de estos dos países
tiene previsto celebrar unos juegos olímpicos.
El caso de Tailandia es especialmente paradigmático.
Reciben casi 6 millones más de turistas que
Japón y tienen la mitad de población.
Y el crecimiento de su sector turístico está
ligado al crecimiento de la clase media china.
En otras palabras, a medida que los chinos
tienen más dinero, pueden permitirse viajar
y ¿Dónde van?
¡Pues lógicamente, a países asiáticos
que están cerca y tienen distintos atractivos
turísticos que visitar!
¡Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
Aunque los Juegos Olímpicos no den tantísimos
beneficios como parece… ¿Qué problema
hay en que Tokio quiera tener sus propios
juegos?
¿A quién no le gusta tener un estadio gigantesco
en su ciudad?
Pues… ahora lo vamos a ver.
MEDALLA DE ORO… AL GASTO
Todos lo sabemos… los juegos olímpicos
cuestan dinero.
De la noche a la mañana, Tokio va a tener
que construir un estadio olímpico, capaz
de albergar a más de 80.000 personas y, por
supuesto, dejarles sin aliento con luces y colores.
También van a necesitar lugares especiales
para que se celebren todas las competiciones
deportivas.
Cada una con sus especificaciones.
No es lo mismo una pista de atletismo que
una piscina olímpica o un estadio para competiciones
de piragüismo.
En total, se van a construir o remodelar 31
edificios.
A eso hay que sumarle el centro de prensa,
que también es otra superproducción arquitectónica
y, por encima de todo la Villa Olímpica.
Una especie de miniciudad donde vivirán los
más de 10.000 deportistas que participarán
en los juegos.
Por supuesto, esta villa tampoco es barata.
En total, todos los Juegos Olímpicos se presupuestaron
en el equivalente a 6500 millones de dólares
estadounidenses.
Al menos, esa es la cifra que dieron las autoridades
al Comité Olímpico Internacional en el año
2013.
Pero ya se sabe… una vez empiezan las obras,
las cosas no son como se habían planeado…
Los costes los juegos Olímpicos de Tokio
2020 siguen subiendo
Para diciembre de 2017, el Ayuntamiento de
Tokio ya se había gastado más de 12.000 millones.
Y sólo un par de meses más tarde, en la
última rueda de prensa, las autoridades locales
avisaron de que, como mínimo, terminarán
gastándose más de 20.000 millones de dólares
¡Y todavía quedan 2 años para encender
el pebetero!
En realidad, nada de esto es ninguna sorpresa.
Desde que se tiene memoria, todos los Juegos
Olímpicos terminan costando más de lo que
se había presupuestado ¡Y no hablamos de
unos pocos millones de dólares!
Los juegos de Río de Janeiro de 2016 terminaron
saliendo un 51% más caros.
Pero, sin duda alguna, el record lo tienen
los de Montreal de 1976, que terminaron costando
un 700% más de lo que se había presupuestado.
Para que os hagáis una idea, eso es 8 veces
el dinero que había previsto.
Y os preguntaréis… ¿Todos estos miles
de millones de dólares… son mucho o poco dinero?
Es decir… para el presupuesto que se gasta
un ayuntamiento o un país entero… ¿Hablamos
de cantidades grandes?
Pues la respuesta es SÍ.
Para que os hagáis una idea, con 20.000 millones
de dólares, Japón podría construir, por
ejemplo, una autopista que cruzara el país
entero de norte a sur.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
lo peor!
Veréis, construir autopistas o aeropuertos
puede ser un despilfarro… pero siempre se
puede reutilizar.
Un país con buenas comunicaciones puede albergar
nuevas empresas, nuevos sectores económicos
o, simplemente, dar mejores servicios a los
ciudadanos.
Pero ¿Cómo se puede reutilizar un estadio
olímpico con capacidad para albergar a 80.000
personas?
Si nos vamos a ejemplos pasados, la respuesta
os va a dejar con mal sabor de boca…
Los edificios olímpicos de Río ya están
en estado de desastre
El caso de Río de Janeiro es especialmente
duro.
Pese a haber tenido juegos olímpicos, todavía
quedan barrios enteros que ni siquiera tienen
una línea de autobuses que les conecte al
centro.
Y, por lo visto, las zonas donde estaba la
villa olímpica se están convirtiendo rápidamente
en barrios marginales.
Y lo peor es que este no es el único ejemplo.
El Estadio Olímpico de Atenas está en ruinas
10 años después de los juegos de 2004
A todo esto tenemos que sumarle el hecho de
que Japón tiene la deuda más grande del
mundo entero.
Y que el gobierno ya tiene problemas, incluso,
para pagar las pensiones de sus jubilados.
Hablamos, además, de un país, que lleva
más de 2 décadas sin crecer económicamente.
Así que la pregunta es… ¿Significarán
los Juegos Olímpicos de Tokio la ruina de
Japón?
¿O tal vez los japoneses serán la excepción
y serán capaces de sacar algún beneficio
después de tantísimo gasto?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y si queréis saber más sobre ese modelo
económico japonés que tiene algún que otro
problema… haced click en este vídeo.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.